what i will give the republicans is that
because of the populist takeover of many
republicans they forced the
establishment's hand
kicked out a bunch of the neocons and i
gotta admit
there as much as i'm not a fan of the
idea of voting against a party
democrats have crossed the line to such
a degree
we are we are at we are at we are at one
of the most dangerous points in american
history
you think i'm exaggerating check out the
story we got from the timcast.com
alpha demo that is to say this website
is not live but you can get a
quick little glimpse of what this
website looks like anyway to the
important news
biden admin is pushing companies to
censor vaccine misinformation in texts
you know the funniest thing about this
story is so we're getting really close
to the launch of our website
we've got a bunch of uh amazing talent
writers and journalists and
investigators
we're gonna be bringing on an
independent fact checker to work
off-site and just do fact checking on
our article it's gonna be fantastic so
we're gonna have an editor
and then we'll have a fact checker and i
see this story pop up
from uh from the writing crew and i'm
like there's no way this is real
and i i legit was like when i biden is
trying to censor private text messages
there's no way the government is going
to a private phone company and saying
shut down their private texts
all right i'm like this has got to be
some hyper partisan rage bait trash
what's the real story and i'm like i'm
gonna have to email
people and be like guys guys guys like
we gotta have a better review because
there's no way this is it's true
the story is real i i fact checked this
i duck i went through it and i was just
like
i gotta have a little bit more faith in
my my my writers man
they wrote this up and it's legit joe
biden and the dnc
are going to phone companies and telling
them to
what are they what are they saying um
sort through sift out and meet out
misinformation i don't think they should
even have the ability to do that
personally oh of course they do like of
course they have the ability to do it
but at what point are we just like well
they've set the constitution on fire
i don't know man those texts should be
encrypted this is crazy well you got to
use
uh yes signal um and there's probably
other apps i guess
mine says encrypted chat right says
encrypt the chat uses the uh the matrix
protocol telegram
look at this quote biden's allied groups
including the democratic national
committee are also planning to engage
fact checkers more aggressively and work
with sms
carriers to dispel misinformation about
vaccines
that is sent over social media and text
messages
the goal is to ensure that people who
have difficulty getting a vaccination
because of issues like transportation
see those barriers lessened or removed
entirely what does that mean
this dispel misinformation yeah but like
look yo we it was like 2016 when they
started censoring people and were like
man this sure is like 1984.
then it was like 2017 and luke is like
hey look i made a shirt where it's brave
new world 1984
and what was the other one fahrenheit
451 all together and now i'm like it's
been
four years since then dude and it's only
gotten worse and now biden's like
come on man i'll censor your text
messages and where's like
the the pitchforks i don't know this is
quiet it's happening quietly
part of the problem i didn't see it on
an msnbc yet maybe maybe this is why i
will pick it up
this is a whole new level of beyond
you know a big problem with this that is
is showing its head to me is that
a year ago well even like six months ago
talking about the lab leak hypothesis
was considered misinformation and would
have been censored so
right i don't know what's going to not
be considered misinformation in the
future that's considered misinformation
right now that would cause people to
have their entire
phone history it's censored or what is i
don't know all right
put them on track in the report from
politico they gave us an example
charlie kirk he's the example yeah
charlie kirk they say
needs to be censored why because turning
point usa
had a tweet where they said that biden
is i'm paraphrasing is sending out
goons to go door to door to make people
who are not vaccinated to get the
vaccine
and they said that's not true that's not
it's not happening
we're just sending out people to go
door-to-door to tell
people to get the vaccine but they can
say no
okay so maybe charlie kirk was being a
little hyperbolic exaggerating a bit
make you get the vaccine they're not
gonna make you do it so you know charlie
pull it back a little bit
but uh i guess it was a fundraising
thing so obviously the sense of urgency
and fear was included in that
all right but it's only off by like the
degree of
of of magnitude by which charlie
expressed the idea they literally
are sending these people out genseki did
say that they were going to have
have uh vaccine volunteers go
door-to-door goons yeah
and they're literally now this is the
craziest thing there's a video i think
to north carolina
where they go door-to-door knock on the
door and then
say would you like to get the vaccine
and they interviewed one guy was like
hey this is fantastic yes
i got to say man look if a stranger let
me just ask you a question
let me ask you i'll ask you guys both if
a stranger showed up at your house
knocked on your door
and then pulled out a syringe and said
can i stick this in your arm what would
you say
no no i'd say no i might not say
anything you might just get suplexed
right there right on my doorstep but
think about how insane that is
that there are people where a guy shows
up they don't know who this person is
how are they supposed to know
and trust it's a doctor it's a random
person they've never met before like i'm
here to inject you in the arm
listen holding a syringe you like the
craziest thing about this is
there's there's counterindications
there's allergies there's literally
doctors who will tell you if you can or
can't get the vaccine
most people are fine to get it but you
still need to like
this stranger on your doorstep doesn't
know your your medical history i i don't
want to get too much into that
necessarily because i'll talk about this
i want to talk about the censorship
but that is happening it is messed up
that's the kind of stuff that they want
to censor they want to
i don't that means dispel you know but
there were a few people who followed up
saying like
let me get this straight like you're
saying they want private phone companies
to like
block these messages yeah this is like
um
it feels like a lot like a hail mary
that
it's an is like this could never have
this could never get pulled off they
could never pull this off this could
never happen
but these kind of things have happened
like i've had that thought of like this
will never happen
the patriot act i was like well they'll
repeal that obviously that thing was
ridiculous by 2005
that'll be wrong now they're using it
here yeah so this is kind of terrifying
you know the they can't just come out
and do it right away right they they
announce this right now
but it's not going to be for a little
while until they actually start doing it
because i got to do it one step at a
time very slowly like increment by
increment
eventually people are just not going to
realize
texts just don't appear anymore and
they're gonna be like oh i must i guess
i can't tweet that and then you know
what the left is gonna say
but dude it's a private company wow
so so ian what is stopping this from
happening because
i'm with you on this one i'm like how
could this possibly happen but the more
i think about it the more i'm like
why not what's stopping a company from
being like all right whatever you say
what's stopping a phone company like
t-mobile from being like i can go
through our data i mean
they probably already use the data from
phone companies to track people like who
were involved in january 6
right definitely i would imagine but i
think common carrier rules i don't know
the actual
restrictions and rules but i think that
they're not allowed to like curate what
can and can't be
said in a phone call or a text
technically i think
at least that's the way i believe it was
supposed to have been right created and
protected
that's because they're like a utility
right yeah yeah their utility yeah you
can't
can't do it but a private company well
so but
well they're there for you isn't is an
agreement you know between
people who use the service in the
company that you know they won't look
through their messages they won't censor
their messages
i think it's the opposite actually you
allow that no i'm pretty sure yeah
everybody when you like turn on your
iphone or whatever they're like we get
access to your information
because how were they supposed to
transmit the information unless they had
access to it right
there's a lot of people understand about
these social media companies where it'll
say like
we have the uh it'll say you know in
terms of service we have the right
to host distribute and you know perform
any content you post create or otherwise
display on our website in perpetuity
blah blah
and people are like they're saying
they're going to take all the rights to
your content and what that really means
is that you're saying you can post this
on your website
like people people don't understand that
in order for like instagram to actually
show
your image they need to have the
distribution rights on that image
to a certain degree and people like
freak out about that like a
non-exclusive
right yeah otherwise you could be like i
never gave them permission to show that
photo
in this part of the world or whatever i
think um mines
had uh before we went over to the matrix
messaging system it was all encrypted
messaging mines didn't have any of the
messages it would only be the end to end
user encryption is what it's called
is that still how it is no well now it's
matrix still end to end user encrypted
it's a different system but
a long time ago so i would think that
these verizon could be doing that with
their texts
they just have chosen not to they've
opted to to gather the data
oh they got to let that go to the you
know nsa right right maybe it's time
that we force
uh legalization or well to me this
sounds a little bit like section 230
because why would a company not want to
be able to say oh oh i have no access to
that information i can't even give it to
like a a security organization i can't
give it to the government because they
don't want to be held liable for that
right yeah exactly so why isn't it
easier for them to just be like nope
don't have it never had it never saw it
no big deal easier but less profitable
that's probably it exactly yeah i can
see it well we're in communist america
yeah it's fun
the democratic party outright is saying
the democratic democratic national
committee
that they want private text messages
text messages censored
facebook and twitter have already
censored private messages and instagram
but instagram's facebook
i remember i was talking to someone uh
recently on facebook and they blocked
some tweet
or some post and it was really really
weird like some we were talking about
something i think something with
immigration and i was like here's a
story check this out and it was blocked
it was from like a regular news outlet
oh yeah
and it was like cannot display cannot
display there was also a period where
you couldn't tweet out uh i think bit
shoot
yeah you might still might be blocked
i'm not sure
yeah so already as we shift our
communications onto like facebook
messenger instead of text because most
people do
a lot of people do they can already
censor what you say between your own
friends
i used to think um technocracy would be
awesome now i'm starting to think this
is technocracy this is what happens when
corporations
tech technical corporations take over
control the government yeah but like
why would i assume that mark zuckerberg
or jack dorsey or bill gates know
how to actually manage people they don't
they don't they know how to build
software code they know how to well not
bill gates entice people with algorithms
is he not a developer i don't even know
if he's he's a salesman him and steve
jobs are just business guys
they were really good at manipulating
people and doing the deal i think he did
some early development didn't he
gates i don't want to go too i don't
know no i don't think so yeah i
literally don't think i don't know maybe
this is a technocracy maybe not a
communism maybe this is a technocracy
it's technocommunism bro techno
communism yeah yeah it's
coming has been forced and controlled
through the manipulation of
communication technologies communism for
the few at the
what it top when has it ever not been
that and then i love it that's not real
communism it's like well every single
time you've done it that's what it's
turned into
you know it's funny it's like you tell
them two plus two equals four and they
say that's not real four
it's like bro every time you put these
things together you get four
but it's not real four it's five well
their argument is like
humans are too evil and selfish in
nature for capitalism to be fair but
they're perfect human beings and they
can have angels and saints just
controlling the redistribution of wealth
and that will never happen yeah but it
always happens
yeah yeah i i think the biggest problem
with communism is that we have the wrong
kind of human
i've said this many times i'm like if we
had perfect people this would be great
i think more than a technocracy this is
like so this is almost like ai
because you know humans program the ai
and make it happen now we're just using
humans to try and censor these people
we're using these fact checkers people
like
glenn kessler who are just fantastic
people like politifact
we know these people check facts in a
very biased way
so we're like one step closer to ai but
we don't have any kind of there was
there was a famous fact check where
bernie sanders said something like half
of any inner city youth are unemployed
and then donald trump said you know it's
a horrible statistic half of our inner
city kids
not getting jobs and then with bernie
sanders politifact is like mostly true
and with trump mostly false
because it's subjective it's an opinion
what is mostly true or false about it
yeah it's like maybe and maybe not means
the exact same
thing yeah pessimistic optimist we hate
trump so he's mostly wrong we like
bernie so he's mostly right
full half empty isn't it really weird
you know eric weinstein tweeted this he
said you know i swear the country was
completely
different a completely different country
a few minutes ago like what happened
yeah
yeah no joke like the chain between the
factions just
severed and now you have the left who
are saying
they're just like when i when i think
about the modern left
i see a bunch of people just standing
there beat
red screaming at the top of their lungs
and when i think of the right i see a
bunch of people with their eyes half
closed smug waving american flags
that's like my my im like vision of the
left and the right
right now so you can't have a
conversation with people who are just
standing there screaming at their lungs
do you guys see this viral video of the
woman
who's being filmed and then she drops
the floor and starts screaming and
crying i'm like bro
that is antifa no i don't think so that
is millennials that is auntie it says
white woman
and there's a black woman filming her
and then she's like stop telling me
damn she hits the woman and then just
falls through and starts crying and
screaming and rolling on the ground
weirdly but the weird thing is nobody
around is like
doing anything they're just kind of like
letting this woman folding stuff twitch
on the floor
this is millennials dude like glad i'm
gen z
oh yeah well like but genzie's got their
there i know we're probably
gonna be worse dude you've got these
people who have never been disciplined
and so they grow up and all they do it's
like that woman who falls to her knees
what did she do that when she was like
seven
and her parents went okay dear
temperature we'll give you whatever you
want now she's like
screaming beat red in the face that's
what antifa is
you can't fail me you can't go back back
let me throw a brick at you hey rage
feels good but you gotta get that's why
i do acting and music because you get it
out on
in in a scene on camera and it's
entertaining for people or you get it
out in a song and people cry but it's
like you don't want to do it in real
life
rage doesn't feel good russell it's like
the
best article yeah yeah exactly i don't i
don't think rage feels good oh i love it
it strips you of your focus it puts you
in the animal brain
you you lose control yeah and then it's
like you you get nothing done well if
you're performing you're
failing if you're performing when it
happens then well that's that's a
production after the fact
but like to just break down this with
this woman screaming it is you are
failing you are a failure these antifa
people when they go out and they're
screaming and just banging their heads
and smashing things
that is them failing at life but the
problem is
you know we can make fun of how dumb
they are but there's a lot of them yeah
going around smashing up stuff screaming
and rolling around on the ground
so like when michael malus says that
these people aren't really dumb so
obviously we're gonna win i'm like
ah there's a lot of them there's a whole
zombie horde out there
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time